both both rebel and better talked about
working with you Ricki and that it's
quite annoying not for me what they mean
is I don't know what I mean they
probably just mean I'm annoying you're
annoying
that's like happens like every four
seconds no it's fine it's so much fun to
work with Ricki because he ducks up a
lot and what happens is we start doing
these scenes and we start improvising
and he'll start to laugh and sometimes
you think oh he's laughing at something
funny I did but usually he's laughing at
something funny he did I know this
because sometimes we'll start the scene
and nobody said anything he'll start to
laugh because he's laughing it's
something funny that he thought of
having a picture taken no I funny enough
for the red carpet thing reminds me the
first time we we went to the Golden
Globes
you don't know but we we went on for the
office and it was British and we never
been to anything as glamorous as it or
as exciting as that we got to do the red
carpet and all these super famous people
were there maybe Salazar I don't know
and and then that we want miraculously
and everyone had told us you will not
win there's no way just go and have the
free booze in the food and enjoy
yourself
so we're there and they call our names
and it was crazy and if you look at the
camera footage now if you look at it
they we were on a table so far away from
the stage because you know win and so
the cameras kind of looking for us and
then eventually so Ricky's little face
pops up like a giant and we sort of
fight our way to the stage and the
announcer has no idea who we are so he's
just because Ricky's last name is
french-canadian that hoby announcer says
coming to the stage Ricky Gervais and
Stephen Mosher
and anyway so they take our picture of
all these photos taken and then everyone
says you're gonna be in the paper Monday
in the British paper I was break so it
was the first time I'd ever been in the
paper before and I was super psyched as
we say in America and so we got a photo
and and and are you gonna well we've got
the picture well see if you can spot the
the reason why I was a little bit
disappointed by my first appearance in a
national paper okay this is it
it's so rude
but fan down pan down they had room for
these people the photographer 70 go
seconds he's like what do they want to
say about 20 years old there yeah in
your head I wanted to look like magnum
p.i I actually grew a mustache in high
school because I played lacrosse and I
thought it would make me look more
threatening really it just made me look
like a porn star we need to apologize
we're not that welcoming to you know
most people are so welcoming no I went
up to when she was shooting I was
shooting something in Montreal so I flew
back to see the kids and my wife and
customs everything was fine and then one
week just got unlucky and there was a
guy about my age seemed a bit grumpy and
he said you see he said yeah I said
you're an actor and I said yeah he goes
what do I know you from I said I don't
know if you'd know I mean we did the
American version of your British office
strike one I get it I get it and then he
said my wife and he says she an actress
and I said yeah said what I know her I
said I don't know he said what's her
name and I said Emily Blunt as he was
writing something anyway you you to your
work have become dolls there you are
from the office oh yeah what else we got
we've got you from anchorman I think you
better without the glasses
there you are Formica but that is a
really good dog kill the guy with a
trainer do now you have a lovely way of
using social media as a tribute to your
partner Jane yeah I just yeah I like
you're in the bar faces that you do I
get the bar faces but then I also get
pictures with we're out or something I I
sort of like lag behind and get Jane by
herself with no one and I take a picture
of her and I tweet Jane with all their
friends
I don't know how funny Jane finds these
so here's one you choose of Jane Jane
thought you've made a new friend but it
was just a shot
this is exactly what you're describing
Jane thinking about making new friends
does she not know you're doing it
there's nothing where is he where is he
he sees the tweet this one is Jane is
looking so happy because her new friend
hasn't walked away yet when you're when
she's posing for one of these pictures
does she go is this one of those
pictures where you're gonna make it or
like I have no know there had to be
there hadn't been a few words at home
after you posted this one just found
this photo of Jane when she was little
[Laughter]
they're giving her a good start yeah
well there you go that's what big years
oh I did an audition for the Dana Carvey
show where I did a bit called the the
German who says nice things so he was I
thought it would be funny to just stand
in front of people and yell things
through the German accent I think one of
them was and get some frozen yogurt
[Laughter]
those legs are built for catwalk okay
appreciate that that's all me yeah have
you done catwalk come I don't catwalk
yeah let me just think um I don't care
what modeling have I don't camp modeling
impress anyone corridor walk well I you
know I have specific walks for different
environments certainly because of the
height so yes I went to the I went to
the doctor and he told me that I had to
stop bending as I went through doing
this as I went through doorways because
I could get curvature of the spine
Oh No so yes because obviously when I'm
because most doors sort of come to there
on me so I have to do that and he said
don't do that he said bend at the knee
instead so I should have a different
when I go through doors I have to sort
of it's glamorous isn't it and it's not
the coolest way like if I have to x-ray
I have to sort of subtly well I'll see
you guys later
Stephen you have almost the opposite
situation when wife and I were driving
down sunset and you know they're these
tour buses that drop drive around
Beverly Hills you know open top tour
buses oh that's where whoever lives and
and we don't live around there but we
were driving through I don't know we're
having dinner or something and we pulled
up next to a tour bus and my wife said
Oh roll down your window and say hi see
what see what they do
oh no good do it come on it'll be fun I
roll down the window hi nothing
[Laughter]
[Music]
you